- And what are you selling here?
- I'm selling my asshole.
(sexy jazz music)
- Hey there, I'm Aria,
and we're here at the
AVN expo, the world's
largest adult convention.
And I figured what better way
to get the full experience
than to spend a day working
here by running my own booth.
The little hiccup, I guess,
is that I am not a porn star.
And so the only actual
merch I have to sell
are these head shots I took when I was 18.
- [Kingsley] Hey, all I
have is my business card.
- This is the one I submitted for Glee.
- Aw.
- Yeah.
This is the one I
submitted for Gossip Girl.
- I love that show.
- Unfortunately, after
an hour of no sales,
it became clear that nobody was interested
in stopping by my booth.
Well clearly it's not going
too well here, any tips?
- I would walk around.
- Taking Kingsley's advice,
I figured that walking around
would also give me a good opportunity
to learn more about the convention.
- And what are you selling here?
- I'm selling my asshole.
- She's not lying, oh my, that is, that is
- My asshole.
- And what are you guys doing here at AVN?
- What are we doing here?
We're bringing the party.
- AVN is like the Super Bowl of porn.
The AVNs is a coming together
of people celebrating sexuality.
- I think that a lot of
people just think that
we're probably a lot of just
trashy, drug, STD-infested
crazy, low-life people, and
we're actually thriving and
doing quite well, and actually,
we're really happy because we're able
to express our sexuality so openly.
It's more of art, like you
know, everybody getting together
and appreciating the work and what we do.
- I love the models, I love the fans, just
it is a great community to be a part of.
- I've never felt so much
love than I have this week.
- For me, I'm in heaven here.
People come up, they
talk, they want to know
about the industry, I want to tell them
about the industry, educate them.
- We're really just
business people that are
trying to network with
other business people.
- I'm actually running my own booth,
and I want to ask you for your expertise.
I'm trying to sell these
head shots of myself.
(laughter)
I'm trying to sell my own merchandise.
- Your asshole?
- Ha ha, I love it man.
- Wow.
- Oh my god.
- They're sexy.
- You could play like
the hot younger brother
who like seduces the MILF from next door.
- That's very specific.
- This one's really fucking cute,
but god damn, look at this one.
- Get rid of the smile.
- I don't like the smile at all.
- You don't like the smile?
- It shows a very, when I see--
- It shows that you're
just a little too nice,
and this one so shows
that you can get naughty.
- You're about to fuck some shit up.
- I'm wondering how much do you think
I should be charging people for these?
Five dollars?
- How much are you, Callie, you'll give me
more than five dollars.
- Five dollars too?
- If you had like say some
skin, maybe ten bucks.
- It's a lack of skin on there.
- There's no body, so I mean ...
- How much skin should
I have been showing?
- Oh, you gotta have
the dick out, now, now.
- This is limited edition, I
only had 50 of these printed.
- Oh, thank god for that.
(laughter)
- I think you could easily
get like a 50 out of it,
like that lip, ooh.
- You guys are being too--
- You have a beautiful pout.
- That should be like around 40 or 50.
- Head shots are five
dollars a pop, generally.
- Would you like to buy one for 40 or 50?
- I think the going average
price is maybe 10 dollars?
- Ten dollars?
- Eight by tens are ten dollars at least.
- You probably could maybe pull
off a desperate ten dollars.
- Mm, ten?
- I would say ten bucks.
- I do think you can sell some.
- You believe in me Riley?
- I do.
- It's all about your
attitude, it's all about
your personality, and it's
all about having confidence.
You put yourself out there,
you make these people say
hey, look at me, you're good to go.
- Is there any chance you'd be interested
in buying a head shot
of mine for ten dollars?
- I'm wondering if you'd be interested
in buying one of my head
shots for ten dollars?
(laughter)
- Hey I'm good, big dog, I'm good.
- Well, you're very
handsome, but you know,
I have no need for your
head shot or I would.
- Come on man, I need one of a girl, man.
What am I gonna do with a
picture of you, man, come on?
- I don't know, you do whatever
you want late at night,
I don't judge.
- No, I like girls.
- I'm trying to sell my head shots here
if anyone would like to buy one.
Ten dollars for a head
shot, is anyone interested?
Would you be interested in
buying one for ten bucks?
- Um, no.
(laughter)
- Um, I think I'm good on the head shots.
- Nah, not today.
- No thank you.
- No I'm alright, thank you.
- Does it make any difference
if I offer to sign it for you?
- Not for me it doesn't.
- (laughs) I have no cash.
- Aw.
- Maybe if it was a better grade of paper.
- But thank you so much,
have a great day guys.
- Oh yo, this guy's gonna buy one?
- Alright, sure, yeah.
- You're real, you're gonna
buy one for ten bucks?
- Oh my god, are you serious?
- That's amazing, thank you so much.
- Trying to make it rain now.
- Brian, oh my god, Brian is a life saver.
Which one would you like?
- I want this, I like the side view.
- And this one's like,
hey, what's going on?
I'm everybody's best friend,
so I'll take the best friend one.
- You know what, you are my best friend
for buying this head shot.
What compelled you to buy this?
- I mean, you're such a
likable guy, you know?
- Anytime somebody's
selling something here,
we like to support.
- I know what it's like to
kind of promote yourself.
I know what it's like to
go out there and hustle
and market yourself like we're doing here,
so much respect to you, 'cause we're here
doing the same thing.
- I'm gonna write something
inappropriate on here for you.
To Brian, I hope you enjoy
this picture late at night.
- I definitely will,
definitely have me some,
some type of dreams with this one.
- I managed to sell three
of them, I managed to sell--
- Three?
- You did?
- You sold some?
- I sold some head shots.
- Oh my god, yeah dude, confidence.
- Take away from this
is that this community
is incredibly supportive of one another,
and I am very thankful
that they supported me
in my endeavors today, so
that's it from me here at AVN.
And if anyone out there
wants to buy a head shot,
you hit me up, ten dollars.
- 15 with a signature.
- 15 with a signature, she's got it.
- [Kingsley] I'm proud of
you man, that's awesome.
(sexy jazz music)
- Do you have any final
words you want to say
to your fans, your viewers
out there, or just in general?
Oh my, that is a tongue.